let's jump into this first story and
just talk about what's been going on
with these lockdowns
la restaurants are forced to close amid
rise in covid 19 cases as california
coronavirus hospitalizations hit highest
point since march the daily mail reports
some la restaurants that have prevailed
through the pandemic lockdowns are now
closing their doors as cases rise mainly
due to the indian delta covet variant it
comes as they all see an increase in
cases and california has seen infections
rise to 5063 per day or a 160 percent
increase from 1 900 wait what is this oh
i'm sorry from 1946 two weeks ago
botega louis and the village idiot have
posted on their instagram pages about
closing the village idiot said it closed
because a fully vaccinated staff member
was diagnosed with the virus
at least seven counties in california
making up more than half the state's
residents are urging residents to wear
masks indoors
california's hospitalizations due to
cover 19 have more than doubled in the
last month according to the la times now
uh you may get you guys may have heard
la they're doing mandatory masks indoors
las vegas says we get this
on tuesday chicago mayor lori lightfoot
suggested she may may she may make masks
mandatory like la as cases increase
164 percent in a month from 34 per day
to 90 per day and they're going to say
the it's it's they're blaming this on
delta but let me highlight something
else
mitch mcconnell warns there could be
lockdowns if americans don't get
vaccinated as the delta variant
continues to wreak havoc i'm just going
to come out and say man it is going to
be incredibly difficult to convince
people that they should get the vaccine
if we're hearing at the same time
they're planning lockdowns regardless of
the vaccine so i whenever we talk about
this stuff you know what we say go talk
to your own doctor
yeah you know you know it's really crazy
though we're watching all this stuff
happen there's a lot of stuff we'll get
into in a minute too especially with
like the economy you know joe biden's
town hall
for some reason
it has now become
i guess uh on the left
anti-vaxxer to say
talk to a doctor about what's right for
you
so
yeah so there was there was a post by uh
uh casey neistat cool dude big fan right
i've known him for a while he's cool
dude
and he just put get vaccinated and i
said no talk to your doctor okay like
don't be so absolute yes you'll probably
end up being advised to get a vaccine
i'm not saying don't get vaccinated i'm
saying talk to a doctor a lot of people
say like oh my doctor's not smart or i
don't trust my doctor it's like okay get
a better doctor yeah if i if i invited a
plumber to my house and i was like my
toilet's clogged and he was like i
recommend smashing it with a
sledgehammer i'd be like bro are you a
plumber or not like i'm gonna find a
plumber who's gonna be like i will fix
your toilet you know what i mean so
anyway look right i said
go to a doctor
ask them you know just five minutes not
even just hello doc what do you think
you know here's my age here's my my
history the doctor says well here's what
i think but for some reason i am getting
attacked by a ton of people who are like
that's anti-vaxxer they're like why be
so dumb
it's actually against the rules on
youtube
to tell people not to go to a doctor
this is this is the point we're at right
now where
regardless of the news regardless of
what's going on with lockdowns you have
i guess vaccine zealotry
of like just let the strange man come to
your door knock on your door and give
you a vaccine it's like well yeah but
you know if if they do call your doctor
and say
what do you think
apparently that's bad now i guess that's
where we're at
wow you know it's it's it's crazy
because you have
these the government-imposed lockdowns
right and they said
um we are doing this for your your
benefit your safety but then they're
taking away all of control you know
they're taking away your freedom to be
able to
um you know go where you want and do
these kinds of things basically it's
virus and they're basically taking away
your own ability to
to to accurately judge for yourself
you know what the best thing is that
works for you it's it's almost like
you know i don't i don't even know what
to say i really don't i was genuinely
surprised because people responded to me
and they were like you're so dumb like i
get inundated with these tweets where
they're like you're dumb and they're
like the doc will just tell you the
vaccine and i'm like so what's the
problem like seriously here's here's my
here's what i'm here's what bothers me
right
we have the vaccine adverse event
reporting system all right and they
recently like added more numbers to it
and there's like a point zero zero three
six uh um i think it's point zero zero
three six i don't get the numbers wrong
you two will get mad at me but it's like
a very very very very low amount of
reported deaths from uh in varys and
okay so here's what i'm thinking i'm
like okay
what if we could reduce those numbers by
making sure that people talk to a doctor
before they just went out to one of
these you know centers or before this
had to get vaccinated yeah because let's
let's say there's somebody who would
normally have a counterindication or an
allergy and you've got all the
celebrities in the world you've got
people like casey neistat and they're
telling people just go do it and casey's
response to me was that he went to a
parking lot waited 45 minutes stuck his
arm out the window and then they said
carry on good sir and i'm like
would you talk to a doctor first like
i'm like even even at these places they
want you to fill out the form to make
sure nobody allergies or anything like
that
if we could get people to simply be like
hey here's my history and then the doc
said in that rare rare instance
oh hey wait what's that you've got
you've got a glycol allergy or something
like that well i'm going to go and say
don't do it maybe we could reduce vares
and reduce actual uh harm and vaccine
hesitancy and then maybe then we could
actually solve this problem but you know
what man the entire time we've been
going through this covet thing we're
like chickens running around there
that's the thing what we need to avoid
is panic that is the number one problem
and i think we talk about this in march
of 2020 tim you and i the real danger
that we face as a society is panic
if we do this right and we and we do it
safely i think should be at least better
i would imagine the best they can be bro
i don't even know anymore all right look
there's a video there's a video of
illegal immigrants being just like
walked through the southern border
40 border patrol agents this year caught
covered
wow a 900 increase in coveted cases
among illegal immigrants and i'm just
sitting here like bro i don't
i'm trying look the people who watch
this show are not dumb people they're
often correcting us they're like 10 this
what you got wrong emails all the time
and i'm like oh that's a good point how
am i supposed to be like this this voice
of reason when i'm like we really gotta
you know everyone's gotta pitch in go to
your doctor make sure you find out
what's right for you and if you can't
get that vaccine and then they're like
but tim they're just
opening the security gates and walking
people through that are sick and i'm
like man
i don't know what to tell you even more
reason to be careful and focus talk to
doctors and and do things take care of
your own health that's first and
foremost you know what's really funny is
i i think i figured out exactly why
they're mad about the talk to your
doctor thing
because it's like deontology versus
utilitarianism which i reference every
so often and it's the the collective
left are very much like
for the collective good
the needs of the maniac when the needs
of the few right whereas deontology is
it's very kind of broad but the general
idea is you know each each action has
its own action right don't take immoral
actions against an individual and you
like it's not so much about the outcome
it's about the action you take so my
attitude is kind of like
i'm not i wouldn't want to sacrifice
anybody to to any kind of risk factor
but i would also rather i would i also
recognize like okay there may be risks
you know what i mean so how about we
just make sure everyone is as is as
informed as possible so i say each
individual
don't get your advice from people like
me
you find a good doctor who knows a lot
about this you ask them specific
questions to to to make sure that
everything you're concerned about with
your health is covered and then if they
say you know here's what you got to do
you take their advice if they prescribe
you something you say okay i do it all
the time
but they i think the left gets mad
because they're utilitarian they don't
want individuals
to be
taken care of i guess they don't focus
on the act against the individual they
don't care they want the hard numbers
for the large group and the percentages
of people who get
shuffled under or left behind they don't
care about well that's that's that
that's a reasonable way the way that you
put it
but the funny thing about what you just
said and then also what you said earlier
about the panic
about all of these lockdowns is that and
and the fact that they're now closing
these restaurant stores in california
you know because somebody got the delta
variant of covet is that we already knew
based on the vaccine people's own data
that you could still get covid from the
vaccine and then you know the covid may
be less effective but you could still
die so okay a person may be less
effective the vaccine may be less
effective so you know what
you know you so somebody you know got
hurt
from covid from the delta variant but
that's still within the realm of
possible outcomes it's still an entirely
reasonable alchemist as to what happened
and you shouldn't make a completely
panicked
move because of that you know what what
they're saying now is that
be well for one they're saying almost
all of the cases and deaths are among
people who are not vaccinated
and we're still seeing a lot of stories
about people who are getting it and are
vaccinated but you know i always try to
tell people
be careful about what the media
highlights you know what i mean it's
this it's the scaling problem right
because there's so much media and
there's so many people of course if you
give out 360 million doses or something
like that 336 you're going to get a
large amount of adverse reactions
relatively large you know depending on
what your perspective is and then news
outlets are going to start snatching
that up and writing about every single
possible one so it's that's why i might
just talk to your doctor because they
might be like look at this chart you
know what i mean right it's kind of um
on the media not to panic society
because these these these shutdowns were
really only because we didn't want to
overload the hospitals in the beginning
and it was only going to be 15 days just
to make sure we could handle this mass
what we thought would be a mass influx
of patients which turned out i think as
far as i know we never really had that
mass just you know hospital over some
places
some places there are videos of of like
people who go around they were going
around during the height of the pandemic
and finding empty hospitals
but i think people misunderstood that it
was like key areas were absolutely
overloaded now as for you know new york
we know that there were there were some
patient issues in hospitals in new york
and so cuomo decided he would just
murder people instead of actually
utilizing the mercy or the javits center
so he was warned if you put sick people
in nursing homes you'll kill all these
old people and he was like whatever
because if you were to put them in the
mercy or the javits center which were i
think the mercy had like one bed used
and the javits was at 30
so we we did set up this great amazing
center like we're really worried about
this and he was like did you ever find
out why he didn't use the hospitals i
mean in my opinion it's because it would
have made trump look really good
but about here's what they're saying
they're saying right now because um
because people didn't get vaccinated and
this i i'm not i'm not entirely sure if
this makes sense but this is what
they're saying
because people didn't get vaccinated
then transmissibility uh was was still
running rampant between people among
people who were not vaccinated which
resulted in mutations which resulted in
a more resistant vaccine resistant
strain which
somewhat reduces the efficacy of these
vaccines and now you're getting fully
vaccinated people who are getting sick
with delta because i think they said it
was like 88 percent but the thing i i
doesn't quite make sense uh um i'm not
i'm not quite sure that actually makes
sense because
youtube actually has a rule
that you cannot say the vaccine prevents
covid like that's actually in youtube's
rulebook
so i'm like well if if the vaccine
wasn't ever 100
then
people could still get covet it could
still mutate and still become vaccine
resistance i'm i'm not sure you know
what i mean you know what look
i don't i can't speak to
the science on this one for sure we had
dr chris martin said on the show he made
his case in the members only podcast but
we did pull up
scientific journals like studies that
contradicted even what he was saying and
i'm like
you know people are going to pick and
choose what they trust and what they
want to believe plus you've got the the
censorship of communist youtube to deal
with i honestly have no idea that's why
i'm like don't don't come to me for
advice but i can't say one thing
when you're ushering people through the
border the biden administration and not
doing anything about it i don't think
they're serious at all i really don't
think they care i am inclined to agree
and you mentioned earlier about them
being utilitarian um but i'm not sure
that you can look at the way that those
texas democrats left the state with zero
masks and who are now going back and
spreading cobit among their own people
and i don't think that you can look at
the border and say that they actually
truly care
about the good of the whole when they're
actively promoting policies that make it
possible for what 900 increases in
coveted cases at the border that's
absolute insanity to me they don't care
they don't so when mitch mcconnell's
like we're gonna go back to the way
things were in 2020 it's like well i
guess so because not like anybody in the
government has any idea what's going on
when we said the 900 increase of border
covet cases is that like gone from one
to nine or is that like no it's like it
was like 14 to 190 something or whatever
okay okay yeah now to be fair to be fair
that's a good point ian yeah because we
did see a hundred and eighty 000 people
crossed the border this month alone yeah
i haven't we've already hit a million
this year uh so far it's only june and
by the end of the year we're going to
have 2 million so it's exciting so 180
000 you said across the board 88 i think
and 180 cases out of 188 000 people uh
i'm not entirely sure if that's of all
if that number is pertaining to all of
the people who came through be healthy
friends yeah yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time